bonjour à tous je suis très heureux de
vous retrouver pour vous parler de Loki
saison 2 malgré plusieurs mois d'absence
je ne pouvais pas louper le retour de
notre fameux rendez-vous hebdomadaire
pour échanger sur la série la plus
pertinente et importante de Marvel j'ai
pas mal de choses à vous dire sur ce
premier épisode et je suis très curieux
de voir vos avis et vos théories en
commentaire la série suit directement la
fin de la première saison après avoir
découvert la fameuse statue représentant
un Kang et s'être entretenu avec Mobus
et B1 qui ne le reconnaissent pas Loki
est en Caval dans tout le TVA jusqu'à ce
qu'un drôle de phénomène surgissent le
Time sleeping et cela explique déjà
beaucoup de choses cela avait été
l'objet de nombreuses théories dans la
saison précédente est-ce qu'il existe
plusieurs TVA est-ce que l'entreprise a
été reset et bien pas vraiment Loki a
simplement time slipé il est victime
d'érran temporell au sein du TVA ce qui
fait que ce dernier dernier au sein du
TVA est capable de voyager dans le passé
dans le présent et même à un moment
donné dans le futur concept complètement
inédit et qui va nous permettre d'en
découvrir beaucoup plus sur cette
mystérieuse entreprise et élément qui
mérite d'être précisé c'est que Marvel
studio prend beaucoup de liberté
concernant le TVA pas mal d'idées sont
nouvelles et propres au MCU comparé au
comics où c'est beaucoup moins développé
typiquement Mobus ou encore obby qui
sont clairement mis en lumière dans le
MCU alors que dans les comics ils sont à
la limite de l'anecdotique direction la
cellule de crise du TVA bien évidemment
après ce qu'il s'est passé dans la
première saison entre la révélation que
tous les employés du TVA ne sont en
réalité que des variants qui ont été
kidnappé avec en plus la mémoire effacée
ou encore ce qu'il s'est passé à la fin
des temps avec la mort de celui qui
demeure et la ramification du flux
temporel tout ça c'est un sacré délire
qu'il va falloir gérer et il y a
énormément de choses à dire sur cette
scène du point de vue de Loki qui est
actuellement dans le passé nous sommes
témoins d'une grande salle de conférence
avec en fond une immense ornementation
avec la tête de cinq variant de Kang la
série Loki aime beaucoup les détails
Marvel mise beaucoup sur cette dernière
ils savent à quel point elle est
centrale dans cette nouvelle saga du
multivers et donc bah bien évidemment
rien n'est laissé au hasard si pour
certains il pourrait s'agir d'une
sculpture représentant un seul et même
Kang en plusieurs déclinaisons et ben
moi je me demande si nous ne sommes pas
plutôt face à la représentation d'un
conseil peut-être que je me trompe hein
mais dans l'univers Marvel plus
précisément dans les comics il existe
des conseils cross temporalité on va
dire du genre des variants qui se
retrouveve pour comploter et agir au
sein du multivers c'est le cas notamment
bah du spy ider verse c'est le cas
également avec le Conseil des rid
Richards alias Monsieur fantastique des
Quatre Fantastiques justement et on en a
déjà pas mal parlé sur la chaîne mais
c'est aussi le cas de Kang et pire que
ça le MCU nous a déjà tisé à plusieurs
reprise des réunions de ce personnage la
scène post-crédit de quantumania en est
le parfait exemple mais surtout celui
qui demeur avant d'obtenir ce titre nous
a expliqué que lui et ses variants ce
sont retrouver pour partager des savoirs
comprendre le multivers et par
conséquent bâtir quelque chose ensemble
nous savons très peu de choses sur le
passé du TVA mais d'après la fin de loky
saison 1 et le premier épisode de la
saison 2 c'était une époque où le TVA
était dirigé sans filtre par celui qui
demeure ou possiblement un variant de ce
dernier mais bon il n'était pas question
en tout cas de ekeepers à cette époque
il y avait déjà une ramification du flux
temporel et apparemment le dirigeant
souhaitait laisser le flux temporel
créer de nouvelles branches néanmoins on
ne sait pas ce qui s'est passé encore
avant et là il y a moyen de concorder
avec les comics il se pourrait qu'à
l'origine mais vraiment à l'origine le
TVA n'était qu'un lieu servant de
réunification pour les variants de Kang
avant que celui qui demeure au moment de
la guerre multiverselle écarte tous ses
autres lui-même pour prendre la pleine
direction puis par la suite du coup se
cacher derrière la création des Gardiens
du Temps de retour dans le présent la
scène nous montre les juges du TVA en
train d'écouter un record de Loki
dévoilant toute la vérité sur ce dernier
et là pour moi quelque chose fait sens
cette scène bien qu'elle serve à
introduire le dialogue concernant les
futurs changements à faire dans le TVA à
l'avenir et bien elle sert aussi à nous
montrer l'utilité de la pièce c'est un
endroit de conférence et de réunion où
il est possible d'écouter des
enregistrements par le biais d'un
dispositif présent sur le mur une fois
de nouveau dans le passé nous sommes
témoin que l'appareil est là-bas la
pièce n'a pas bougé et l'épisode étant
bien monté Loki va naturellement se
diriger vers le dispositif nous sommes
témoins d'un enregistrement de celui qui
demeure faisant l'éloge de ravona
rensleayer bon c'était la suite logique
pour le personnage ravona à la fin de la
première saison est parti en quête du
véritable dirigeant du TVA et surtout et
bah c'est on va pas se mentir c'est
l'intérêt amoureux de Kang dans les
comics l'histoire d'amour du personnage
avec normalement à l'origine la
princesse ravona possède un poids énorme
dans l'épopée de kangle conquérant
ravona dans les comics elle est à 100 %
rattachée à lui c'est limite sa seule
utilité scénaristique là-bas cette
fameuse histoire d'amour donc c'était
sûr que le MCU allait ramener cette
liaison néanmoins comme je vous disais
intéressez-vous à la construction de la
scène salle de conférence réunion de
personnages écoute d'un audio pour
certainement en débattre par la suite
pourquoi du coup nous avons tous ces
éléments dans le passé et bien si
c'était pour nous faire comprendre
subtilement la réunion de plusieurs
Kangs ou peut-être simplement d'autres
gens dans le TVA écoutant la menace que
symbolise celui qui demeure le variant
qui a écarté tous ces autres lui-mêm
c'est une idée je vais peut-être un peu
loin mais je garde ça dans un petit coin
de ma tête ensuite après les fameuses
retrouvailles entre Mobius et Loki nous
faisons d'ailleurs la révélation qu'il
n'est normalement pas possible de
voyager dans le temps au sein du TVA une
logique qui a été amenée dans la
première saison car le TVA est en soit
une zone nulle dans le sens où elle
n'est reliée à aucune temporalité aucun
univers du coup cela place Loki en tant
qu'entité vraiment unique il est comme
un bug dans la matrice un bug qui lui
permet d'outrepasser les règles de plus
élément que je trouve intéressant c'est
que la dynamique entre Mobius et Loki a
désormais changé ce qui était pertinent
dans la première saison c'est que Mobius
nous servait de point de repère il nous
servait à comprendre le TVA il était
celui qui avait les réponses à nos
questions contrairement à Loki dont nous
partagions les yeux puisque tous nos
repères étaient chamboulés tout comme
lui par conséquent cela créé une
certaine dynamique ou Loki servait
beaucoup de cautions drôles entre
guillemets de par son ignorance du monde
qui l'entoure sauf que désormais c'est
l'inverse Loki a vécu la fin des temps
il a découvert la vérité sur le TVA il a
rencontré celui qui demeure il sait
maintenant des choses que Mobius ne se
doutait même pas par conséquent c'est
désormais Mobius dont les repères sont
chamboulés ce qui appuie du coup la
crédibilité de Loki et qui de l'autre
côté rend Mobius un peu plus drôle face
à oroboros soit le serpent qui se mange
la queue la représentation pure de la
boucle un chemin qui ramène à son point
de départ mais nous allons y revenir un
peu plus tard Loki et Mobus rencontrre
ce nouveau personnage afin de régler la
question de l'érance temporelle la scène
est très bien construite Loki time sleep
une nouvelle fois dans le passé ce qui
va lui faire du coup rencontrer un
oroboros plus jeune permettant au
passage de concevoir une solution à son
problème et ce qui est très intéressant
avec cette scène c'est la venue d'un
paradoxe très célèbre dans les histoires
de voyage dans le temps c'est le
paradoxe de Bootstrap
oboros nous explique qu'il connaît
Mobius que la dernière fois qu'il l'a vu
c'était il y a 400 ans et que ce dernier
l'appelle avec le surnom obi du coup
Loki à ce moment-là vient d'apprendre
ses informations de la bouche
d'Ouroboros ensuite il va time sleeper
et il va retourner dans le passé là-bas
comme on l'a dit Loki rencontre contre
un noboros bien plus jeune et il lui dit
est-ce que je peux t'appeler obi et
oroboros va répliquer obi h ça me plaît
bien en lui disant ça il vient de donner
naissance au surnom obi à oroboros alors
qu'il l'a lui-même appris de la bouche
d'Uroboros c'est le paradoxe de
Bootstrap c'est une boucle dont nous
perdons l'origine c'est un peu pareil
avec ravona d'ailleurs renslerer existe
grâce au TVA mais au final d'après les
dir de celui qui demeure elle a permis à
ce dernier de gagner la guerre
multiverselle dont le résultat va
permettre la naissance du TVA TVA qui va
donner naissance à ravona vous voyez un
petit peu l'idée la saison 2 de Loki
tourne autour du concept de boucle et
c'est marrant parce que c'est un sujet
de vidéo que je vous avais écrit avant
que je m'absente pendant plusieurs mois
celui qui demeure nous a tisé ce fameux
concept dans l'épisode final de la
première saison mais nous aurons
l'occasion d'y revenir durant la série
face au cœur temporaire nous sommes
témoins de la cause d'un possible futur
effondrement du TVA le multivers est
quelque chose de naturel lorsqu'un
événement Nexus naît au sein du flux
temporel cela crée une nouvelle branche
une nouvelle réalité une réalité avec
autant d'habitants qu'il en existe dans
la réalité originelle par conséquent
couper les branches de l'arbre c'est
donner la mort à un nombre incalculable
de personne Multiverse of manness nous
l'a d'ailleurs très bien expliqué ainsi
quantman quantouania mais
malheureusement bien que sur une
question morale ce soit bien de ne pas
élaguer les branches du flux temporel
évidemment de l'autre côté le TVA ne va
plus pouvoir suivre surtout que c'est
exponentiel tout comme un arbre les
branches peuvent donner naissance à
d'autres branches qui elles-mêm donnent
naissance encore à d'autres branches
donc le TVA ne pourra pas tout gérer et
la preuve en est c'est que Loki va nous
le montrer en voyageant dans le futur
là-bas nous faisons face à un TVA dans
une situation de crise sans pareil les
codes vis visuel ont changé le TVA
semble être dans le chaos les alarmes
retentissent de partout en fait il
semblerait que nous sommes en quelque
sorte dans l'épisode final de la saison
2 toujours cette thématique de la boucle
c'est un concept que Marvel avait déjà
tisé dans la première saison avec
l'entretien en compagnie de celui qui
demeure nous comprenons que la fin est
en fait le début car avec la guerre
multiverselle celui qui demeure va
émerger en tant que grand gagnant et à
partir de là il va donner naissance au
TVA sauf qu'avec la ramification du flux
temporel et la mort de ce dernier c'est
donc de nouveau la guerre multiverselle
qui se prépare mais qui va sortir
victorieux de cette dernière bah c'est
celui qui demeure bien évidemment c'est
une boucle temporelle Loki saison 2 va
donc pleinement explorer ce concept et
le premier épisode exploite tout ça dans
le futur comme on s'y attend il y a trop
de branches à gérer pour le cœur
temporel annonçant l'effondrement du TVA
et par conséquent le véritable retour de
la guerre multiverselle de l'ordre né le
chaos puis du chaos naîtra l'ordre en
cherchant à se faire brouiller afin de
s'extraire du flux temporel Loki dans le
futur sera attiré par le bruit d'un
téléphone juste après nous avons le
retour de Sylvie qui apparemment
cherchait Loki puis contre toute attente
ce dernier sera finalement brouillé de
la main de quelqu'un d'autre nouvelle
boucle loky vient de se faire brouiller
par lui-même par son lui du futur nous
voyons la silhouette de son autre lui
dans son dos et en soit c'est logique
qu'il se brouille lui-même car bloqué
dans le futur Loki n'a aucun moyen de
s'autobrouiller sauf que s'il existe
dans le futur c'est qu'il a survécu par
conséquent en sachant qu'à ce moment
précis son luit du passé serait présent
l'oki du futur va intervenir pour
brouiller son luit du passé afin
d'assurer sa propre survie Sylvie semble
d'ailleurs épauler l'oki du futur dans
cette quête et je pense très sincèrement
que nous reverrons cette scène lors de
l'épisode final pour faire écho
justement au premier épisode comme une
boucle concernant le téléphone je vous
avoue qu'il y a un mystère pour moi et
je n'ai pas spécialement de réponse il
se pourrait que ce soit juste un élément
pour attirer l'attention du Loki du
passé ou bien qu'il serve de timer
d'alarme mais je vous avoue que je sais
pas trop je trouve que c'est peut-être
un peu simple comme idée surtout qu'il y
a un gros focus sur les téléphones et
qu'il y a l'idée que si Loki du futur a
déjà vécu ce moment il s'en rappelle
donc vous voyez l'idée bref je pense
qu'il y a une symbolique derrière cet
objet mais nous en auront certainement
plus dans les prochains épisodes
d'ailleurs je le place là mais dans le
futur j'ai remarqué également un haster
egg ou du moins une sorte de détail qui
n'est clairement pas le fruit du hasard
quand Loki arrive dans le futur au
milieu du chaos nous voyons le logo du
TVA avec des document le recouvrant et
le truc c'est que je trouve que les
feuilles sont placées trop précisément
pour que ce soit un hasard normalement
en TVA c'est time variance authority
mais avec les documents sur le logo nous
voyons écrit time author l'auteur du
temps peut-être que c'est simplement
esthétique pour la scène mais je sais
pas je pense qu'il y a sûrement une
signification est-ce que cela a un
rapport avec celui qui demeure qui
devrait émerger dans la série ou bien
est-ce annonciateur d'un futur rôle pour
l'oki dans l'épisode final voilà à vous
de me dire vos idées enfin comme
l'annonce la fin de l'épisode la suite
devrait se tourner vers Sylvie dont nous
n'avons encore aucune nouvelle cette
dernière est apparemment dans une
branche du flux temporel elle est
toujours dans ses habits de la première
saison ce qui nous laisse largement
supposer qu'elle sort tout juste de la
fin des temps et désormais libre du coup
car on rappelle qu'elle est enfuite du
TVA depuis son enfance et bien elle peut
désormais profiter mais au final pour
combien de temps dans tous les cas outre
la direction artistique les OST ou
encore les plans rien qu'en un épisode
la saison 2 nous a tisé la menace que
symbolise celui qui demeure l'un des
variants de Kang plus que jamais il
n'est pas présent et pourtant on ressent
clairement sa présence et la dangerosité
qui le compose le futur chaos qui se
prépare lié à lui et franchement ça ça
fait plaisir espérons que la suite aille
dans ce sens et que ça soit toujours
aussi Cali de mon côté j'espère que la
vidéo vous a plu et si c'est le cas vous
savez quoi faire on se retrouve la
semaine prochaine pour l'épisode 2 si
cela intéresse certains d'entre vous je
vais certainement faire un post dans
l'onglet communautaire pour vous
expliquer les raisons de mon absence
voilà je suis très content de vous
retrouver les vidéos c'est quelque chose
qui m'avait clairement manqué c'était
argoroc les amis que le lion heart soit
avec vous allez ciao tout le
[Musique]
monde